And it is a great place for political discussion.
Okay.
Donald Trump's approval rating has surged
to the best of his presidency.
Say the headlines in the Gallup presidential
approval poll.
Okay.
So in the Gallup presidential approval poll,
Donald Trump is now polling 49% approval.
This is as of Tuesday morning, which was before
the state of the union address a reality show
extravaganza that he did on Tuesday night
and before his acquittal on impeachment yesterday.
So we don't yet know how those two events
will affect his approval rating 50% according
to the Gallup poll disapprove of Trump, 49%
approve.
So a lot of Trump is have gone absolutely
crazy because of this and believe that Donald
Trump is clearly a shoe in for reelection
in November.
And of course they may be completely correct,
but what it is important to understand is
that this is just Gallop.
It's much more uh, informative and contextualized
to look at an aggregate of Donald Trump's
presidential approval.
And if you look at the aggregate both nationally
among all Americans or even among likely voters,
the approval rating has not moved very much
for Donald Trump.
So let's look closely and as you can see from
the five 38 aggregate from approval rating,
there really hasn't been, I would say not
much of an uptick.
There's really been no uptick.
And Donald Trump's approval rating is actually
still on average lower right now than it was
in mid November.
Now you can also counter by saying if Trump's
approval is historically low for a long period
of time, when it becomes more normal, it looks
like a big increase.
But that actually ignores the data, which
is that Donald Trump's approval rating is
basically steady.
But the really important thing to think about
here is not actually whether Trump's real
approval rating is at 49 47 or 42 the most
important message to take away from this is
that regardless of whether it's at 49, 47
or 42, reelection remains likely for an incumbent
president with an approval rating in the forties.
The increase or decrease or the shift or the
exact number that's less important.
What matters is that George W. Bush was reelected
in the year 2004 despite being relatively
unpopular.
Now, there is no question that one can make
the case that it was because of irregularities
only in the state of Ohio, which he won narrowly.
And had he lost John Kerry would have become
president of the United States.
But regardless, it came down to just a hundred
thousand votes in Ohio, even with, uh, Donald,
uh, George W. Bush, not a particularly popular
president, uh, Barack Obama at this point
in his presidency in the same Gallup presidential
approval poll, was it only 46% approval while
Donald Trump again is at 49.
So the important takeaways are it is really
difficult to knock out an incumbent president
even with an approval rating in the forties
we've talked before about how you can make
the mathematical case where a president could
actually be reelected even with an approval
rating in the low thirties or the high twenties
now it would be unlikely because you need
high support in certain States and then you
can mathematically have almost no support
in certain state.
Like you can do it because of the electoral
college.
It's not the most likely scenario.
But if it's possible to be reelected with
a 30% approval rating with a 49% of 47% or
43% wherever it is you believe Donald Trump
actually is, it is no sweat to get yourself
reelected.
So this stuff really matters now in the next
week to two weeks.
What I want to pay close attention to is what
happens to Donald Trump's approval in the,
in the aggregate overall now that he has been
acquitted and impeachment and after that state
of the union address and several very good
days in the stock market.
And as we know, the stock market, something
that in practice affects way fewer people
than it affects in ideology and for PR purposes.
People see the stock market climbing.
Even if they don't have shares of stock, they
still start to believe that it's because of
something that the president is doing.
So what do we need to do?
Well, if the democratic primaries continue
being a fiasco, if the economy stays superficially
strong and it's important to know that I'm
using the term superficially, it is going
to be a tough uphill battle to knock out Donald
Trump in November.
The reality impeachment is that impeachment
was the right thing constitutionally it was
the right thing from the point of view of
this is a responsibility of the house of representatives
to bring impeachment charges when the facts
support them and warrant them.
The reality is that we have to figure out
a way to win.
And the other reality is that it is not surprising
or unexpected that polling support for the
president would consolidate as we close in
on the election, particularly if the democratic
party continues to be framed, not totally
inaccurately as inept in its ability to just
conduct a simple primary where as of this
recording, we still do not have results a
full three days after the Iowa caucuses completed
in Iowa.
So do I, uh, am I giving up?
Am I suggesting anyone give up?
Of course not.
But what I am telling you is that there are
a real obstacles here to removing Donald Trump.
Another one will certainly be that there is
going to be foul play.
There is already voter suppression.
The tactics and the strategies are already
being employed.
And if Donald Trump does lose in November,
I do not believe that he is going to go peacefully.
I don't believe there will be a peaceful transition
the way we have defined it in the United States
for hundreds of years.
And that's what I'm going to talk about after
the break.
Make sure you're following the David Pakman
show on Instagram for more on this and every
other story from today's show
at David Pakman show on Instagram.
While you're there, while you've got the app
pulled up, I follow me on Instagram as well